cette demeure de la fin du 19e siècle
situé dans la commune d'arradon
christophe triboulet la connais très
bien depuis trois générations sa famille
est propriétaire des murs mais pas du
terrain qui appartient à l'état sur 500
mètres carrés de superficie 300 sont une
emprise sur la mer est donc un élément
du domaine public maritime
début juin les tribus les ont reçus une
nouvelle injonction de démolir la maison
familiale de penan mère avant le 1er
janvier 2022
en france ce cas n'est pas une première
et certains ont réussi à obtenir gain de
cause
pour christophe triboulet la justice
française est à deux vitesses dans les
calanques de marseille des outer ont été
délivrés aux ti du patrimoine et des
outer sont délivrées aussi au titre du
patrimoine sur l'île aux oiseaux dans le
bassin d'arcachon est donc effectivement
on a deux poids deux mesures c'est à
dire que si vous êtes corse et si vous
êtes marseillais les choses se passent
plus facilement pour vous le dpm est
beaucoup moins strictes et les a ôté
sont donnés pour plus facilement
on a un état de droit mais mais le droit
s'applique différemment que vous soyez
en corse en paca ou en aquitaine et
encore moins en bretagne tous les cinq
ans la famille de christophe triboulet a
pu bénéficier d'une a ôté une
autorisation d'occupation temporaire du
domaine public
la loi littoral de 1986 a changé la
donne et six ans plus tard un bras de
fer juridique s'est engagée vingt ans
après les triboulet doivent s'incliner
mais en 2011 alors que l'élection
présidentielle approche l'autorisation
d'occupation temporaire est reconduit
pour dix ans une décennie plus tard la
maison doit être finalement détruite
comme ordonné en 1999
une aberration pour certains habitants
et riverains
je pense que c'est dommage qu'elle fasse
pas qu'elle disparaisse pas ce qu'elle
est elle a toujours fait partie du
patrimoine moi c'est vrai que je vais
passer beaucoup de mes vacances ici
étant jeune et j'ai souffert la maison a
toujours été là on sait qu'on est arrivé
à penne remen parce qu'on a les
tourelles de chez les tribus les et puis
les tourelles du petit fortin qui est là
bas
voilà donc non il faut pas la détruire
c'est loin d'être une verrue dans le
paysage et il ya certainement autre
chose à faire et je pense que même
plutôt serait plutôt valoriser cette
maison je n'y habite plus longtemps
c'est leur maison de famille
même s'ils n'ont pas eu permis de
construire mais sa date d'exiger sa jupe
à catane et l'acte de propriété un sens
vous un peu car la maison se situe sur
une ans classé par la direction
régionale des affaires culturelles pour
empêcher sa destruction christophe
triboulet a lancé une pétition qui a
déjà recueilli plus de 40 mille
signatures face à cette mobilisation la
préfecture de vannes a voulu renouer le
dialogue
sollicité par la rédaction de rtl france
elle n'a pas souhaité s'exprimer sur le
sujet mais la famille triboulet obtenu
quelques avancées
monsieur le préfet essaie de trouver la
solution pour que ma mère puisse garder
cette maison jusqu'à sa mort c'est à
dire qu'à sa mort la maison ne serait
pas démoli et elle irait
elle retournerait dans les clae
retournerai au préfet et le préfet
donnerait les clés soit la mairie
d'arradon soit au conservatoire du
littoral
christophe triboulet souhaitait obtenir
une nouvelle autorisation d'occupation
temporaire sans succès donc mais un
deuxième rendez vous avec le préfet est
prévue au mois d'août à vannes avec
l'espoir pour la famille triboulet de
pouvoir encore jouer quelques années de
leur havre de paix